so the president gets to declare
his uh his top priorities and for the
longest time immigration and border
enforcement was it wasn't even on the
radar screen with president trump it was
in the top five i think it was number
three and as a result of that we got
access to um bunch of agencies that have
techniques skills tools technology that
goes well beyond what we've ever
experienced and that really enables us
to start painting a better picture along
the border one of the things that's
happening right now is that up until
about 2010 2014 i think was more
realistic
most people coming across were single
adults right yeah so they were arrested
um some were prosecuted some were just
simply returned back into mexico
in 2014 people began to realize that
they could exploit the asylum loophole
in other words i come here and i say
theo i want asylum right and because of
that i've got to process you and then
i've got to release you and when i
release you now you have access to state
aid
you get a work authorization and you may
not have a hearing for five years and
that's if you elect to show up and a lot
of people don't show up for their
hearings so they don't necessarily
qualify for asylum um and i think that's
it's one of the shortfalls of this
because you you've really
um you've
bastardized the definition of asylum and
for those that truly need asylum now
they've become one of a million people
asking for it and you've you've taken
that away from them right and at the
same time now these folks are using the
system against
the system in order to benefit from them
from it excuse me and so the family
units they come in they ask for asylum
uh they get into the u.s and they
disappear looking at today right now
with the situation at the border um
it's a crisis is it a crisis oh
absolutely and i'll tell you why it's a
crisis
there's a focus on kids there's a focus
on family units um so in 2019 we had
we had a border crisis then and what
made it a crisis was these two
populations families and kids what they
do is they cause the system to just to
come to a complete grinding halt right
because there is no law enforcement
entity in the world that's designed to
house
or care feed
children and families right yeah so we
often heard um you know negative
backlash about oh
you know it's inhumane treatment and x y
and z but nobody's situated for that but
when you get
i think it was 100 almost 200 000 family
units and something like 80 000
unaccompanied children when you put that
into the system
that's not designed for it it just it
stops it's gridlocked and then
everything else falls apart behind it
you can't prosecute you can't house
criminal aliens
so
the system will collapse
it's a crisis on multiple fronts first
and foremost
because it's not being addressed the
flow is going to continue right you know
the unfortunate part and for the border
patrol
we're apolitical you know we're
worked for 32 years under different
administrations
every administration you know you you
give them the facts you tell them what
what's going on what you think is going
to work what's going to benefit
and then you step back and then you fall
on the line
this administration was briefed on if
you reverse
these programs if you take these steps
this is what's going to happen and
unfortunately sure that's what
happened we also have to recognize that
covet has impacted these countries
probably much more severely than it has
us you know the medical capabilities
aren't aren't the same as they are here
in the u.s right
um
so you're getting a population of people
that are coming into the u.s
we're we're not doing koba testing on
them so you have the the potential of
another resurgence of covet in the u.s
part of what happened
when kovitz started back you know last
year
is we implemented what's known as title
42 which is the ability to when you come
across i make the arrest and i expel you
immediately i don't bring you into a
station
my goal is to get you back across the
border and out of the u.s as quickly as
possible to minimize that exposure
um and they that was started during
covet yeah okay so prior to that it was
you're arrested
driven to a station processed
and with kovid it was you don't even
come into the station and we get you out
of there was that kind of nice that's
great but the only problem with it is
that so when i came to border patrol in
88 we were just arresting people you'd
process them and you'd return them right
back to mexico and then you'd see them
again in the same shift or the next day
and so is this a constant revolving door
with title 42 we're kind of there again
because all the courts are shut down so
there's no prosecution there's no
deterrent you can't house them so you
put them back on the border and the
smuggler says hey
i'm taking you back across you know you
paid me i'm going to get you back across
and they just keep on doing this until
the biden administration recognizes that
that they are
their actions and their words
are having an impact they're driving
illegal migration
until that changes this is going to
continue so when we talk about crisis i
mentioned the system coming to a
grinding hold but the bigger issue is
that
there isn't enough from this
administration saying
you can't come here right you know
you're going to be prosecuted or
the the reality behind this whole thing
is and
people may find this uh quizzical
thinking you know here's an enforcement
officer but our immigration system has
to be revamped and you have to think
about this as it's it's a whole system
the enforcement part and the legal part
if you fix the legal part then that
enables the enforcement part to focus on
the true criminals the really bad
elements when you have a legal system
that's
messed up and is not working well that's
when you get all these people that take
the illegal route and then it just
burdens border security
so you know i'm a strong advocate of
whether it's this administration or the
next one
somebody has to come in and fix our
immigration system as a whole really but
they can't do it half-assed you can't
focus on the legal part not the
enforcement part or you can't take apart
the enforcement part and then bolster
the legal part you need to do it
simultaneously so that you've got this
immigration system this umbrella that
works well
the title 42 thing it was also about
preserving our medical system in the u.s
because we wanted to make sure that we
had ample medical care for us residents
right right right if you allow this
population to come in it can overwhelm
the medical system
but when we have people being released
at the border so now you have to house
feed care for you have to provide
medical care for them so some of these
border communities are not equipped for
that you know not equipped for a surge
of a thousand or twenty thousand people
coming in on a daily basis
and so it overwhelms them you know they
don't have the deep pockets to pay for
this stuff and right now the
government's not doing anything to help
them out
is it hard for
border patrol agents like some of them
whether they're to set aside any
political beliefs they may have and just
do their job do you see any of that or
most of the guys like you said
administration just changes over time
and um and you guys just kind of stay on
the task at hand
you know it does bother you personally
of course you know you want somebody
that's supporting your endeavors um but
you don't take it to work um you know
again because we're gonna every four
years you have the potential for working
for a new boss right and the rules can
change every four years
what's uh i think what's what's
fortunate for the agent in the field is
that you know you're you're tasked with
enforcing the laws that have been
legislated by congress right and so even
though the president may not like those
laws it's the law and it's hard for him
to change it or her to change it maybe
someday um so you you try to stay
apolitical but it certainly bothers you
when you're not getting support we need
congress
we need the white house but more i think
congress more anything kind of to
to get in the game right um you know if
i can be blunt it's congress needs to
get its head out of his ass
and start doing something right they
have the power of the purse and the
power to legislate right
they need to apply
the purse towards addressing this
helping with the kids the family units
they need to legislate they need to
revamp the entire immigration system
and you know i applaud the bite
administration for looking at you know
what do we do to invest in
the source you know where are these
people coming from right
that's great and we always try to do
economic redevelopment in these
countries but they have to recognize
that you could you can't put a billion
dollars
in
el salvador today and expect it to stop
this flow right you have to recognize
that it's going to take 10 or 20 years
before that plan comes to fruition
so in order to make things better it's
it's revamping the immigration system
it's helping some of these sending
countries but it's also having a very
strong effective
immigration system that includes the
border enforcement right you just you
can't undermine it and whether it's
technology more agents more
infrastructure whatever it may be you
need to secure that border congress has
to do its job i mean it really hasn't
done anything towards
um addressing the problem uh and a lot
of what's going on right now is uh
congress's fault from the last two or
three years because a lot of the funding
that was earmarked for um detention for
remodeling detention facilities was
removed from the budget because part of
the intent was to ensure that people
were being released okay so now you fast
forward two years and what's happening
we can't hold these people so we have to
release them
so it's it's a vicious cyclical game and
i would just hope that uh our elected
officials just focus on the problem it
not only for the humanity of these kids
and these families but also for the
bigger aspect of the border security the
one thing we didn't touch was terrorism
yeah i assure you
and i can't speak to specifics because
there's classifications behind it
but there are folks that have terrorist
ties terrorist training that are intent
on hurting us that have come across our
southern border what do you feel like is
some type of a solution or something
moving forward
it's the legal aspect it really is it
needs to be revamped you know what you
described about programs
refugee programs are well established so
where you're sponsoring refugees as they
come in in different category from an
asylum seeker right um
but there are programs for that where
it's whether it's a church group or a
particular individual that supports that
refugee and then helps them assimilate
and you know
become part of america
really we
the key is legal migration but it's got
to be a system that's just much more
effective and efficient
the reason people start coming across
illegally is
you may apply illegally but it's going
to take you three to five years right
and then the categories again a lot of
what we have are unskilled labor right
um
you know
i agree with one thing that president
trump did talk about was
if we're going to bring people in
why aren't we bringing in more skilled
labor you know we're not we're not the
country that we used to be 40 50 years
ago where we had a great demand for
unskilled labor right we have a greater
demand for skilled labor your technology
folks you know stuff like that
so if we're going to do this it has to
be revamped so that it's addressing the
particular types of skills that we need
but it's also done in such a manner that
it's just it's effective it's we live in
a world where we want things now right
nobody wants to wait two or three years
and that's part of what's driving this
illegal migration is if i apply legally
a i may not qualify b it's going to take
me forever to hang and then c right now
if i come across illegally i'm going to
get released at least that's the mindset
that's what we're seeing on social media
and chatter and
debriefs that we do with the folks we
encounter and that's some of the stuff
that's really the worst because that's
how people are learning about it and
getting inspired really like now's the
time you know oh yeah yeah i mean
they're on social media facebook
instagram twitter it's out there
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one